when the AppStore began almost a decade
ago things were simple pay once used
forever people would happily pay five or
even ten dollars for a good game and
when demand grew for apps so did supply
more people in the business of making
apps meant more competition and a
dangerous race to the bottom the average
price of a game is about 49 cents and
it's been lowering for years all of this
competition has made many switch to
freemium where apps are free to download
with optional premium upgrades this
would seem a great solution apps can
still make a profit through upgrades but
we get our apps far far cheaper how
great is that but as it turns out cheap
can be quite expensive when the price of
apps fell companies didn't just decide
to settle for less money they got very
clever
remember if you aren't paying for a
product chances are you are the product
instead of paying with dollars and cents
we pay in time attention and privacy the
most generous apps cover your screen
with ads praying that you accidentally
tap one in a moment of poor coordination
but many are far less kind they
manipulate your brain with tricks
designed to deceive you for as much
profit as possible and in some cases
it's even worse the company movie pass
recently decided to lower its price to
just ten dollars a month that's a free
movie every day for basically the price
of a single ticket this should set off
your alarms movie pass hasn't become a
movie charity something else is
happening their goal is to collect as
much user data as possible which can be
used for marketing purposes or sold to
third parties so this means movie pass
is no longer a product for consumers but
a product of consumers likewise when
people stop paying for apps they invite
developers to find new ways to stay
alive even if it means selling their
users but maybe you'd happily sign on
this dotted line sure you don't like ads
but at least your apps are free sadly
this is only going to get a lot worse
developers that resist freemium will
keep making less and less money until
they go out of this
the market actively selects for and
encourages poor practices and will keep
doing so getting worse and worse over
time the good news is that it's not too
late there are things everyone can do to
stop this race to the bottom firstly
Apple is the all-powerful god of the App
Store they decide who is allowed in and
who gets blessed by better promoting
paid apps they can encourage that
business model and by allowing a free
trial feature people would be more
likely to try and eventually pay for
apps next developers in many cases they
change their practices not because they
wanted to but because of demands forced
upon them the solution is not to
silently accept the changes but to
communicate the problem if you pay for
this app we don't have to exploit you to
survive and we can even afford to update
it in the future
lastly we the consumers are largely to
blame
we need a new mindset not of always
finding the very cheapest app but
sometimes being willing to pay for apps
we want to stick around of course some
apps will and really should stay
freemium but it has gone too far and we
should be trying to reverse this trend
you